本日は
2017年1月13日金曜日明日中4日の土曜日15日の日曜日と
センター試験でございます
図研製の皆さん勉強を突かれたので弾み社長です
8この動画はですねひとまず受験生の皆さんそしてちょっとしたら今後内閣に行きたい
なとか思っている
みんなに向けての動画でございますよかったら見てくださいそもそも僕ですねなんで
この受験の動画とか付け型の動画をたまに出すかって言いますと
たぶん僕人生で何を一番頑張ったろって言われたら
まつげなく大学受験って答える人間です僕そんな勉強できる人間じゃなかったってのは
中学校の時とかバリバリ a 500鉄16点とかだった試練前夜だったんですけども
そんな損中から何とか頑張って勉強してバカなりに時間をかければ何とかなると思って
何とか皆さんも知ってると思うんですけども復興立大学の静岡大学に進学でき単電源で
ございます何で僕
大学受験というのにすごい思い入れがあって勉強の辛さと数軒のプレッシャーとか
いろんなガボ感じできているし良い苦しくて孤独との闘いというのを吸っているので
トレクル住んでる皆さんが頑張ってるってをもっとこう何か声を掛けたいなって思っ
ちゃってついに受験の季節になるとはを有三がを取ります
受験生の皆さんも多分当日前ですごい緊張していると思うんでまぁちょっとでもね
緊張がほぐれるようなお話をしようと思います今日あなたのは僕の天壇試験当日のお話
でございますずう長野時を点灯して受けたから不純 e 21に中19位
18176年前だよあの戦争からもロックでも取ってるのかまつエク国立大学に行く
ような人間じゃないんですけども
勉強おごりポリーホみたいに勉強してなんとかそこらへんまでたどり着いた
バカですそういう男がですねその必死こいて町弁城した上で挑んだ青+犬だけ食べる
めちゃくちゃ緊張してますか当日はで僕富山県出身だったんでセンター試験当日の1月
めちゃくちゃ吹雪だったんですよそんな悪天候の中のセーター式だったんですけどもう
じきんその11日目のお昼ごはんタイム午前中のテストがなんとか終わっ
でちょっと一段落してお昼ご飯でございますかあさんが作ってくれた弁当
て作り始め頑張れはじめがんばれって好きっとー朝からに頑張って作ってくれた弁当
だったんですよありがとう母ちゃんこれ頑張れよそう思って母ちゃんの弁当食べようと
もだけだ瞬間
橋が入ってないなぁ
ペン大好きなの航行できるわけじゃないんですよねやまけん中の高校生が会場に集まっ
ていけるセンター試験だったね弁当食う4階室はもう他の候補他の知らない人ばっかり
の中で僕があっている卵役とか食ってたわけですよ
センター市宮中でもうその時点で大分も何かメンタルがやられたんですけども
美味しかったよ風おいしかってありがとう当たり馬券ってもう寒いんじゃ冬は結露し
ちゃってるんで老化ターンの凍ったりしてて滑るんですよね危ない釣れるんですけど僕
ちょっとトイレとかせておくれちゃって会場にでも200人ぐらいの政府はみんな着席
してるんですよ静かにてやばいみんな腐ってるとでこう
走っ
て会場に入って自分の席まで行こうとした瞬間運輸課が傷のしてて滑ってあのアニメ
みたいな購入倒れ方はながらこう言っておりました
うんっ
会場に100人の受験生誰一人何もしゃべらず人にも笑いませんでしたあーーありも
笑わなかったですねみんな年にももうするそうじゃなかったらそりゃそうですよね自分
の身の人生かかってるわけですから僕一人が静かな空間で200人の前で困っても誰も
何も笑われない兵士はそりゃログの麺とには火を吹きましたそれがちょっとひと皮むけ
たのか知らないけれどもどうにでもなれと
思ってまずはわりとリラックスして巣に出すにおけることができたという話でござい
ますどうぞ
200人の他人の中で頭から滑って焦げる奴なんてそういないだろうでもう一つ
ちょっと凄いのがあったんですけども変だし気て英語の科目があるじゃないですか
で編男子が抜ける人って高校3年編の人ばっかりじゃなくて浪人生の方とか大人の方と
か色んな人出せ出汁にはその解除
受けてたんですけども僕の前の席にいた女の女性の方が何歳なんだろうな多分30歳
ぐらいの女性だったんですけども英語の資金始まった時にですねなんかめかし金管が
23人ぐらいたんですけど水ん僕の場合の席の女性のとこに来集まってきてじゃんって
この女またがやらかした感じカンニングでも誰かんじゃねーかと思ったんですけどどう
やっ
そうじゃなかったみたいで高校で編みが制服着てセンターしてうけるんですけどもう
一般の女性の方は自分の私服で来てるわけじゃないですか
私服にねなんか英語で単語が書いてあったんですよねかチャットってなんかじゃって
住みたいないとみたいな単語が書いてあったんですけれどもそれがどうやら付
せいだと思われたらしくてへんらしいけど英語ってそのヒントになるようなこと一切
禁止なんでえちゃんを書いてある服着てたらダメなんですよ
これ覚えていってください一般の方はその女の人は英語のセーター着てたんで英語の
セーターの道
脱ぐとほぼ裸みたいな状態だったんですよ女の人は千段式ハタ科で受けるわけにもいか
なかったんでどうするんだろうと思って僕ずっと前でこれ話聞いてたら
服を裏返しにしてください見て永劫山見えることがそのダメだったみたいで結果的に
その1 e 5回だったセーター
裏返しに着て行っを超えて裏返し歴史られて済んだして受けてましたね後ろにいる僕の
気持ちに考えてくださいよ後ろから見たらを組みからこうやって札が見えてるわけじゃ
ないですかまずいい迷惑ですよなんで前の女の人を不正たい
逆に来てセンター試験を受けるんだがこもって不覚にもめちゃくちゃ面白かったと栄養
の試験はなという感じかな僕のセンター試験はそれが来と国語で結構ミスっちゃって
結局が目標というより100点ぐらい低い点数になって振っから志望校選びっていう
感じでまあ今の静岡大学になったんですけどな静岡大学受ける時もね倍率がエグかった
なぁ
6.4倍から64人受けたら中に違うから内膜だったんですけどそこを切り勝ちできる
静岡大学に入れたという僕の大学受験でございました本気で勉強してきた人は非常に
緊張していると思いますあってても罰になっちゃうのは本当に悲しいことなので
センター試験はダンズレマークシートの断ずるだけ気を付けて下さい以外
痛い日々が続きました僕も緊張と不安でつらかった分良い未来が待っていると思います
大学入ったらもう好きなことできると思うんで
髪の毛だっても金髪にも茶髪にでもしてくださいぜひ
明るい未来に向かってもうひと頑張りでございます受験生の皆さん頑張ってください
良い結果を期待しておりますじゃじゃーん
me
ああああああ
あっひっ